now y'all know democrats never let a
good crisis go to waste even if they're
caused by joe biden the disaster in
afghanistan has resulted in a flood of
refugees coming to america so where are
they going according to axios thousands
are headed for the battleground state
the democrats were desperate to win in
2020. how convenient including arizona
georgia michigan north carolina florida
and my home state of texas now why would
biden want to send him there and here's
something funny the guy in charge of
this job joe biden's buddy the former
governor of delaware and wouldn't you
know it out of the 37 000 refugees only
30 are headed to his state and none of
them are going to washington d.c
hearing how to react is karl rove former
white house deputy chief of staff and
fox news contributor now carl now i'll
admit this i'm a libertarian i'm always
skeptical of government but this seems a
little fishy am i wrong
well i'd be concerned a little bit
because for example you i've got my
little handy map here from axios you're
right a thousand refugees are going to
florida
but
montana exchange idaho which is 1 14 the
population of florida is getting 420
you're right they're 1.3
1 300 going to michigan but there's 775
going to nebraska which is a fraction of
the size of michigan so i wouldn't i
wouldn't see this as a plot i am a
little bit concerned about why it is in
delaware doing its fair share but
really these decisions typically are
made between the state department the
department of homeland security based
upon a couple of factors one of which is
the ability of resources at the state
level to accept these refugees and
properly treatment but but also looking
at particularly this is the case with
with the so-called siv holders that the
people who fought alongside with us
interpreters uh you know military aides
and so forth they have sponsors and the
question is where is their sponsor the
person who's willing to help make
certain that they get settled in the
united states and start to make their
their their life here in our country so
i wouldn't say this is all sort of you
know you know some dnc representative
sitting in some weird office in
washington saying let's have these
people put in uh certain states so that
15 years from now 18 years from now if
they become u.s citizens that they'll
vote democrat in a battleground state
for us i think it's it's it's it's not
that not not not that underhanded so
carl i want to go deeper into this
because i've been traveling across the
country i've been to these processing
center by the military
bases and talked with the veterans there
and the wives are the ones that are
handling this transition making sure
they get the toiletries and and help
with that transition part of the reason
why they wanted to do it is not just out
of the goodness of their heart and they
were very nice people but they were
promised that these were people that
helped america in afghanistan but we
don't know for sure all those folks are
right now so what do you know about that
when are we going to start this process
where we know these are the people that
are on the battlefield with our troops
and their families
well first of all there is some
processing going on
on every one of these individuals in
fact in the first wave there was a
report that 44 people out of the first
wave of several thousand were
immediately sent back out of the country
because we had intelligence that these
were not good actors and had no
involvement with us military forces
we've got a pretty good handle on who
did help the united states
some of them went through the siv
process but others have people who are
willing to stand up and say this person
was helpful to our unit in the following
manner so we've got to put we've got to
put an emphasis on that we've got to
treat every one of these people though
as someone worthy of further
consideration and further you know
observation we can't just sort of say
welcome to the united states uh have a
good life we've got to monitor these
people but i you know we have a moral
obligations people i'm old enough to
remember what happened after the end of
the vietnam war and when we had a lot of
vietnamese refugees particularly in our
home state of texas you may remember we
had a real kerfuffle down on the coast
when a lot of when a lot of those
vietnamese refugees went back to what
they were doing back in vietnam which
was fishing but nonetheless they have
become an important part of our country
and i think the same thing will happen
with these afghans they came here not
because they wanted to you know
they wanted to get away from the taliban
they wanted to stand with the values
that they have fought for and stood for
many of them for the last 20 years carl
i i definitely think america has to keep
his commitment
but i also think and you know i travel
around the country covering crisis that
happened in chicago philly and baltimore
and a lot of those folks feel like
america doesn't care about them doesn't
care about their circumstance there's
literally bloodbaths happening every
single weekend and they don't feel like
america is doing a good job there so we
got to be careful about that too carl
yeah absolutely and got to make certain
that these people are observed and make
certain that we don't have problems
hidden among them thanks carl hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else